what do you think because you said it
earlier the side that's just like die
hard they're the leftists the Democrats
what do you what do you think there is
it that that side is just so hardcore
they'll never admit fault because I'm I
don't I don't really have a side day but
like when Trump says stupid stuff like
that I go I go dude he's messing up I'm
in nine different group chats that are
all political and I can't leave because
one of them has a freaking Android they
still to this day bro they won't admit I
will I'll never hear you know what
Biden's messing up or this is they're
just do you think is it they just I
think the machine and the mass
brainwashing is so intense that they
cannot get out of it it's that moment so
when I did Mars podcast a couple weeks I
really want to talk about it and I said
to him you know he kept saying well
Trump's an election denier and I said
well you know Hillary Clinton did call
Trump an illegitimate president she
tweeted it it's on video many times he
was like
his response to me was no that never
happened and he kind of screamed it as
if I completely made it up and then once
I calmly explained no it did happen I
didn't have Wi-Fi so I couldn't show it
at the moment but I've Subs we've been
tweeting about it he had now we've ever
been texting he now acknowledges it's
real but what it showed me was wow even
Bill Maher right this is the gold
standard for liberalism in America for
20 years the left now hates him because
he's an actual liberal right and
unfortunately uh you know the day before
the election he's on MSNBC he's
basically saying you have to vote
Democrats so I guess I guess my my job
did not I did not fully complete my job
no but I tried I tried I think I tried
more than probably anyone has directly
to his face on camera uh but but that
moment where he where I'm telling him
what is obvious what is you know the
Stacey Abrams election denial all of
this stuff and that he did not know I
think that's what you're talking about
so then you tell people basic truths and
it is so out of whack with what they
believe because they watch MSNBC and I
mean not that anyone's even watching it
but the culture the culture stuff that
leaks through to people
and that's why they've been censoring us
for so long right that's why this Elon
Musk thing is so massive because I don't
know if you guys noticed this but even
even I think it started this morning on
Twitter if you look at your your
verified you're verified if you look at
your verified mentions now because
people can buy in because the blue bunch
of new ones you don't recognize they're
not verifying right so on one hand it's
kind of like all right maybe I don't
want to see all these people but on
another hand what is it doing it's
making it so that all of the political
journalists and Daily Beast journalists
all of these people who got the blue
check because they work at these places
so you somehow think oh they must be
legit and important well now they're
just like everybody else and and that
hopefully will cause some of the change
here where the guys that you're in the
group with will somehow some level of
reality will crash into them because the
censorship at least at the Twitter level
maybe is you know crumbled if you're
looking for more honest and thoughtful
conversations about politics instead of
non-stop yelling check out our politics
playlist and if you want to watch full
interviews on variety of topics watch
our full episode playlist all right over
here and to get notified of all future
videos be sure to subscribe and click
the notification Bell